it's not Kingdom Hearts 3 but you will
be able to play through the Kingdom
Hearts series on your ps4 next year I'm
Tony and this is your collected game
spot news update Kingdom Hearts HD 1.5
and 2.5 remix are coming to ps4 the
first collection contains Kingdom Hearts
final mix retain of memories and the
remastered cinematics from 358 over 2
days the second collection contains
kingdom hearts 2 final mix birth by
Sleep final mix and a cinematic
retelling of recoded one of the main
complaints about Kingdom Hearts is that
you had to own a bunch of different
consoles and handhelds to experience all
the games consider that problem squashed
with these releases Kingdom Hearts HD
1.5 and 2.5 remix hit ps4 on March 31st
2017 as for Kingdom Hearts 3 well we
still don't know that much although it
is confirmed to be coming to book ps4
and Xbox one stay tuned to game spot for
any more news about the third game and
for all the latest in the world of video
games you're already in the right place
you